they glide through the water
with unmistakable grace remnants of an
ancient past
they dive and they rise from the ocean's
murky depths
to its sun-kissed shallows rousing fear
and awe like no other creature in the
sea
the world's biggest living fish is a
shark
of the estimated 34 000 species of fish
the largest are whale sharks
these gentle giants usually grow to
about 40 feet long
and weigh an estimated 15 tons
their mouths alone can span four feet
wide
the gigantic whale shark however pales
in comparison to the largest fish that
ever
existed the megalodon dating to over 20
million years ago
it's thought that the prehistoric shark
could have reached 80 feet long
weighing up to around 70 tons unlike
whale sharks
the megalodon was carnivorous and
consumed any creature that fit
into its nearly 10 foot wide mouth
throughout their lives some species of
shark can shed
over 30 000 teeth unlike
humans who are born with a set number of
teeth in their jaws sharks have a
seemingly
limitless supply they can grow lose and
replace their teeth as needed
furthermore most sharks have multiple
rows of teeth in their jaws
the jaws of a great white shark the
largest predatory fish in the sea
can contain up to seven rows that hold
up to 300 teeth at any one point
most sharks as they hunt their prey end
up losing their teeth
individually however the cookie cutter
shark
loses and replaces the teeth in its
lower jaw all
at once
sharks are built for speed
the fastest known shark the mako shark
can reach speeds of up to 46 miles per
hour
the speed is largely due to their body's
hydrodynamic design
many sharks have torpedo-shaped heads
that allow them to cut through the water
with little resistance
plus shark skin is covered with flat
v-shaped scales called
dermal denticles the tentacles help
water flow smoothly over the skin
which reduces friction and helps sharks
swim quickly and quietly
sharks also have skeletons made of
cartilage instead of bone
cartilage is a much lighter material
than bone so
sharks have less weight to carry
sharks may lay eggs or bear live young
egg-laying sharks only lay a few large
eggs
they may come in various forms such as
sacks called
mermaid purses or corkscrews
these eggs act as external wombs in
which shark embryos complete their
development
however most sharks give birth to live
young
called pups the young of most
live-bearing species
gestate for around one year some even
begin practicing their predation skills
while in the womb
before they are born the sand tiger
shark pups compete with their siblings
in fact the strongest pup in each of the
two wombs
devours its weaker brothers and sisters
some sharks are at risk of extinction
every year an estimated 100 million
sharks are killed worldwide
in large part for the shark fin trade
the sharks are caught and their dorsal
fins are removed and sold at a hefty
price
primarily in asia in traditional chinese
culture
serving and eating shark fin is a sign
of status and wealth
because of the high demand and value of
shark fins
some shark populations have plummeted by
up to 70 percent
causing a ripple effect in ecosystems
and endangering at least
74 shark species however
measures are being taken to protect
sharks with a number of countries and
jurisdictions
cracking down on unsustainable shark
fishing
in china shark fin soup is no longer
allowed to be served at government
banquets
a move hailed by shark conservationists
through continued international
conservation efforts
the loss of sharks may be curbed
allowing the creatures
and all their power and grace to survive
for many generations to come
[Music]
you